the blitz itself is also dramatic we
didn't see that in the first game
young christopher wondering when he had
seconds left on the clock and here we go
and here we go and uh after duda pushed
his e pawn forward pushed the king's
pawn forward it's ivanka's favorite
opening again but this time magnus is on
the black side of the karakan are you
happy to see this one on your banker of
course i'm absolutely delighted uh this
is what i dream about and okay and here
we have the fantasy variation it's one
of the sharpest lines there is against
the karakan and white's idea is very
simple just protecting the center with a
pawn and magnus goes for a very safe
approach which is to reinforce the
center it will just develop his pieces
and at the right time break forward with
a timely c6 c5 yeah so uh a fantasy
variation i never knew how to handle it
until recently it was just uh every time
i play online blitz it comes up and i
was just freestyling it's uh really
flexible opening for both sides a
variation at least of the carry gun and
uh okay magnus he's offering a
transposition into the french defense it
started as a carican and it would become
the french defense if white pushes his
central pawn forward
as he has done white's now gonna
continue trying to build space over the
next few moves uh dude first though
retreating the white knight just so you
can kind of build this pawn chain very
sensible and uh is this how you handle
the karo khan no because i don't play
the french defense so i i can't handle
the fantasy in this way no i instead i
prefer to develop the dark square bishop
out and put the pressure on the center
that way and uh
okay but this is something that magnus
is familiar with
and uh we've seen him employ the french
defense uh i'm thinking about his game
against harry krishna
in day think day two or day one of the
preliminaries yeah so magnus has won
with the french defense before that was
actually a crazy game where magnus
sacrificed a piece of peace for a few
pawns just to explode up in the center
this is very different of course but
then again black is the first to castle
black is much better developed than
white but look at this white pawns are
storming forward white is going to kind
of initiate a dark square strategy put
all his pawns on dart squares and he's
just going to try and hope that the
black pieces can't break out from their
cage black's pieces do lack space they
do fight for the same squares that's why
magnus is now trying to open up lines
maybe for his rooks this could backfire
though if white is accurate if white's
pieces get into the game but look at
this all of white spawns now apart from
one on dark squares it's clear what duda
is going for with the strategy it's up
to magnus to try and break out and fight
especially against the head of white's
pawn chain in the center but first he
switches uh attention and just pushes
pawns the white knight though developing
unleashing the white light squared
bishop
i'm i've got to say despite what the
evaluation bar says black has to be
really careful here i love white's
chances if white gets one more move if
white's light squared bishop can develop
d3 square point towards the black king
white already has a ready-made attack
magnus has to be careful now
and uh he puts pressure on white's
center the question is
can white go all in and sacrifice a pawn
and he is going for it now you have to
be a bit careful if you're black you
can't actually grab the pawn that's uh
up for sale because after all the trades
have been amassed there will be a queen
sitting loosely on the d4 square and the
bishop can come and
take a pawn on h7 okay right we're gonna
see it wow
ivanka there's actually a big
opportunity here and duda is calculating
it white has i'm not sure whether it
works but white has the option of what
we call a greek gift sacrifice uh it's a
great gift because you give up white's
bishop white's light square bishop you
can actually go and take a pawn near the
black king luring out the black king out
into the open and then you can throw
even more pieces on the fire you can
throw a knight forward with the track
you can bring the white queen into the
attack
do you think dude is going to go for
this is he just going to recapture this
pawn on your back as you said which is
fine for white white's pawns structure
is just about defensible uh or do you
just burn your bridges gamble and open
the position up sacrificing two pieces
to go for black skinny yeah i did see
the greek sacrifice that you mentioned
where you sacrificed two pieces to open
up the h line
it's risky
it's a lot of pieces and you have to
calculate well he's done it he's gone
for it but he's gone for in a different
way yeah so not giving up the white
light squared bishop to lure out that
black king break it out into the open
instead trying to give up his knight oh
look at the bar
the computer hates this that means the
sacrifice simply doesn't work but in
order to accept the sacrifice you need
courage you need nerves of steel and
magnus if he takes this white knight it
looks like dude is just gifting him a
knight for free if the black pawn
captures this knight then suddenly white
will use his bishop and
open up the black king and look at the h
line that will open up if you take
white's knight white will recapture with
the pawn eventually uh gaining time and
are you obliged to capture that knight
no that's the big thing for magnus if
you take this knight maybe you'll live
to tell the tale and you'll be a couple
of pieces up but look at the evaluation
part again magnus hasn't moved and it's
recorrected itself oh that's how
complicated the position is even
computers need a deeper horizon they
need more time to crunch the numbers
crunch the moves in order to get to the
truth and
if you're sacrificing a piece maybe even
two and the evaluation bar still says
it's roughly balanced that means it's
quite promising from a practical
perspective so really interesting look
at the clock times as well dude going
for it he scared magnus magnus now down
to two minutes dude still with nearly
four minutes and magnus doesn't take the
piece no he doesn't take the piece but
we're still gonna see fire on the board
because uh well duda has grabbed a pawn
in the center but look it's on the same
line as the black queen so does this
mean that black can kind of get fruity
and capture a pawn in the center
clearing the path
for the queen's attack against the
knight and he has played it okay he's
played a different avenue so clearing
the light square bishop black's light
square bishop hitting the white knight
in the center of the board now so kind
of a pseudo-sacrifice offering up your
piece but trying to go for white's piece
so the key here the critical variation
now is for white to actually get greedy
and capture the black rook that white
knight was doomed anyway so you might as
well grab a rook in the process and
black's knight in the center trays
itself off for a bishop so the material
count white has an extra rook but black
has a bishop and a pawn in return and
also black has an open king to attack
and that is very very scary
most french players
they
they dream about these kind of positions
and these sacrifices this is why they
play the french defense
so i
really am very very worried for doodle's
position he has to get his king to
safety he has to control the activity of
black's minor pieces because look at it
he's taken a lot of risks with his pawn
structure there's holes all over the
place
yeah uh dude that does not look
comfortable he is much happier as an
attacker than a defender and now he's
forced on the defensive and i actually
gave lessons a while ago to a 10 year
old child and that 10 year old child
played the french defense he said to me
david
as in
in the french defense if you have a
light squad bishop that's blocked in
it's fine as soon as the bishop gets out
you win the game and that's happening
now magnus carlsen's light squared
bishop is about to come out on the
diagonal
and that piece is possibly going to win
the game for him due to shaking his head
this one's turned
i loved what duder did but it backfired
and uh magnus now giving up a rook not
everyone would have done that he's not
materialistic he's opened up the
position and now black's light squared
bishop is going to come out surely
and uh once it does there we go the
black bishop is out in the french
defense you nearly never see it this
active this piece
and suddenly the white king is under
heavy fire black's rook that rhino is
going to steam over into the center of
the board check that white king and duda
leaning back
is he giving up hope already it's really
dangerous now yeah white
we should mention it's not legal to
castle over to the queen side now to the
left side because that black bishop cuts
over and you can't castle through check
but if you cast on the other side notice
the black queen is on the same diagonal
as the white king there'll be a discover
check due to going on the counter attack
though hitting black's bishop this is
his last chance yeah but this does allow
the queen to dive in grab a pawn attack
the rook where's the rook going to move
i mean okay well okay attacks the queen
and uh well i suspect that the queen
okay we see a check first this is a nice
strategy and
he's just winning ivanka king the king
can't move the white king if it moves
will lose its bishop and if white's
queen takes this black rook then black's
queen takes the white rook white's queen
is overworked if it takes the black rook
it loses protection
of its own work dude is about to lose
this game magnus are just overworking
the white pieces and white's king is
doomed we talked about dude's 26 move
win magnus is winning in 21 moves here
as black
this is impressive
yeah and it was all because of knight uh
dudes very committal night move and uh
there we see a few captures on the board
and it is looking dreadful for white and
look at white's king is defenseless
black now has three pieces two bishops
and a knight for two white rooks but
look at why it's rook in the corner
stuck next to its king look how open the
king is on the diagonals dude knows he's
done this attack is going to be deadly
he's not going to survive that white
king it's living on borough time
i mean
all it needs is a dark square bishop to
come into the game and look it's game
over and uh now a knight is in
and there's is there a big threat in the
in the position yeah there's a couple of
big threats black's queen now is
threatened to come down to the bottom of
the board and that would end in disaster
for white look how white's queen is cut
off from the defense of her king that
black knight in the center of the board
acting as a defender and an attacker
look at that smile on
the champion's face magnus carlsen wins
the charity cup in thai breaks after a
tough fight against john christoph duda
look at that it's nice to see that smile
probably a little bit tired but uh
impressive stuff by magnus carlsen look
at that what is that smile about david